talking about things going well and
things going badly you did some research
about men's suffering and people's
responses to it as well what was that
yeah so
framework was based on Kirk Gray's work
and he has looked at in the domain of
moral psychology he's looked at moral
type casting which is this tendency to
he argues that when we perceive a moral
action we kind of instinctively classify
people as either the perpetrator or the
victim so we have this dyadic heuristic
when we perceive moral actions and so we
took that framework and we looked at
okay might there be a gender bias and
our tendency to place men and women in
the victim and perpetrator categories
and so across a series of studies what
we found was that we more instinctively
classify women as victims and men as
perpetrators and so Kurt Gray's model
argues that when you classify someone as
a perpetrator it makes it more
challenging to see them as a victim and
vice versa so if you classify someone as
a victim it's hard to to see them as a
perpetrator and so these
roles are pretty consequential because
they're associated with sympathy and
blame and so what we found is that
congruent with these this type casting
we found that people more easily blame
men than women and they more easily feel
sympathy for women than men is that both
men and women fail that yes we did find
in some of our studies we found that
women showed the bias to a stronger
degree than did men but we didn't find
that super consistently
um and so I think that this makes sense
from an evolutionary perspective because
if we think about reproduction women set
the upper limit so women contribute they
basically bring more to the reproductive
table they're more valuable
exactly and so if you have a group with
very few women you're not going to have
many babies being produced compared to
if you have a group with a lot of women
you really only need a couple of men to
still produce many babies a couple of
men having an absolutely fantastic time
yeah I'm sure they would be very
delighted until an enemy group comes in
and then they have to having a bad time
yeah yeah so probably wouldn't last long
but exactly so women are more
reproductively valuable so I think it it
makes sense that we might have these
biases to kind of protect women from
harm but this can be really problematic
when we might be less likely to
recognize men suffering so I think when
we think about the distribution of
social outcomes we tend to focus at the
top end of the distribution where we
might recognize like oh women are less
often CEOs less often world leaders this
is certainly true but when you look at
the bottom end of the distribution men
are more often homeless more often
imprisoned more often dropping out of
school they're more likely to die by
Suicide die by drug overdose so men
aren't thriving at this side of the
societal distribution and so I think in
this case it can be really problematic
that we don't recognize or less easily
recognize men as victims and have less
sympathy for their suffering you see
this reflected in IQ distribution as
well right that you have more men at the
top and more man at the bottom and it's
kind of the same the men are just who is
it that said might have been David bus
that said uh
men are Evolutions play things that you
just you roll the dice with them a
little bit more there's more genetic
variation we'll see what happens they're
kind of more disposable because as you
say it's women that set the upper Bound
in terms of uh procreation
so I understand why it would be the case
that we're more prepared to see men
suffer in one regard that they're just
kind of like less they need to be less
protected and they need to be less
valuable the interesting question I
suppose is in a modern world where women
don't need to be cuddled so much anymore
we don't have the same
um physical concerns and yet we have
this mismatch now where the ability to
give sympathy to Men Who perhaps very
much need it isn't there
yeah it is problematic in a modern
environment and I mean for both
for multiple reasons so not only that we
can't recognize men's suffering but also
that we if we're more inclined to see
women in this like patient role this
like suffering victim role it makes us
it harder for us to see them as agentic
and so I think this might contribute to
why we more easily recognize men as
leaders and so it's not always you know
unilaterally positive to see women as
like the patient that's very interesting
yes yeah and so it's like it can be
harmful when you want to you know in the
voting booth you're not going to be
recognized as an agent and maybe not as
a CEO
um but in the context of moral harm
you're not going to be blamed to the
same degree did you see speaking about
the in the voting booth thing Christina
Durante taught me that
in a political race between two women
the woman who loses is the one that has
better marital outcomes long term
like her relationship is the one that
ends up being better long term
for her relationship yes yeah for her
private relationship I just thought that
was so funny it just everything gets
folded into this I remember seeing a
tweet from you as well about Steve
Stewart Williams study Steve Stuart
Williams found that people respond more
favorably to Scientific findings showing
women outperform men versus the converse
people wrongly assumed men prefer male
favoring findings may suggest gender
biases in reviews slash publishing of
research what do you think's going on
there
yeah so I think that because we tend to
you know see women we want we want women
to to have beneficial beneficial
outcomes we put them in this like let's
help the victim category it can make
them more appealing and and easier to
support compared to men if we if we view
men as perpetrators and agents it's
easier to see what they're doing as
malicious and so if we're kind of
encountering information that women are
have some positive trait we're like oh
good let's help them I suppose as well
what would be the social signal that
would give you
um some reflected glory of championing
the underdog if you're championing the
one that in terms of a cliche archetype
is already the one that used to do this
thing that used to overperform exactly
yeah yeah so you look more beneficial or
you look more pro-social by championing
you know women's success because we
assume women are doing worse across the
board which is true at the top end of
the distribution not at the bottom
um and so yeah I think that that can
that's an interesting it'd be fun to
look at like what moral credits do
people get for you know helping women
they're promoting these things that help
women versus men we did actually conduct
a study we haven't submitted it yet but
it was um it was a politician talking
about men's afflictions in the world and
we didn't say what the politician's
gender was
um so it was them giving a speech
talking about all the ways that men are
suffering in the world and then in the
other condition we just changed men to
women and so in that condition it was
the statements were no longer true and
because it was about women and women are
actually in those contexts doing better
so they're like you know not dropping
out of school to the same degree as men
are and so what we found is that people
liked the politician talking about the
female disadvantages even though their
statements were not true so they liked
that politician more were more likely to
vote for that politician wanted to
donate more perceive them as more
immoral even though the statements
weren't true and so it was interesting
because our male participants identified
correctly identified that the statements
were less true but I don't think our
female participants did and so I think
there support some of that bias that I
was telling you about where our female
participants tended to show more
favoritism towards women across the
board which I think makes sense if we
think about our female ancestors they
needed to recruit female allies so one
way to do that might be to Signal hey
I'm on team women which probably
throughout human history was pretty
consequential because say your you know
male partner was being really violent
towards you you would want a female Ally
that was team women because she might be
more likely the recruit social support
on your behalf but if that occurred
enough throughout human history that
other women preferred the females that
had the female bias then that might
contribute to why we see you know modern
women today showing this pro-female bias
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]
foreign